good morning believe ation today's
message is be great over to you Noel
Gallagher they can't be the greatest
band in the world playing in a pub
somewhere tonight the nobody's heard of
with the internet if you're great you're
going to make it yeah you know that's
just a fact you know there's not there
can't be any well we don't make it
because you know working class
assignment you not I mean it's like if
you're writing the best songs in the
world you're going to make it the end
when Oasis came along we didn't have the
internet you know if we divide the
internet with even bigger than the
universe you know I mean we could have
reached everybody yeah you know but we
did it we were forced to do it too hard
wearing you know these new bands have
all the advantage of you know these
devices that can get you to everybody in
the world at the click of a button and
you know all I've gotta come up with is
all right you had the difficult bit is
the songs it's never been easier to win
if you're talented there's nobody
holding you back there's nobody saying
that you can't have success and never
has it been easier to win regardless of
where you come from regardless of how
much money you have or who your parents
are what country you're from or who your
friends are it's never been easier to
win it's never been more about
meritocracy about earning it and so if
you're not achieving the success that
you think you deserve to have it's
nobody else's fault stop making excuses
stop blaming other people take some
accountability it's you you are where
you are because of you you are where
you're because you're not adding enough
value to other people's life and you can
but it only starts to happen with you
accept the responsibility because as
long as if somebody else's fault as long
as your school's fall to your parents
folders the president's all there's
somebody else's fault then you're never
going to take the action because you
have the easy way out because you're
great you're amazing and it's this
person's fault you know it's my ex
husband's fault it's my business
partners fault it's my family's fault
it's always somebody else's
and that's going to be the story for the
rest of your life and you're never going
to reach the potential you can have
because you don't want because you
wanted to stay stuck where you are you
want to just keep blaming other people
and never actually take those big steps
forward you deserve every bit of success
that you have both in a good way in a
bad way and like to say this on my
youtube channel people say that I've had
a lot of success with the youtube
channel and six hundred thousand
subscribers and all that so in the one
hand I deserve those six hundred
thousand subscribers because I've been
putting out a lot of work a lot of
hustle a lot of energy a lot of love a
lot of heart blood sweat tears goes into
making these videos for you every day so
I deserve to have the kind of dollars
subscribers a lot of people will leave
comments amen your videos are so good
you deserve to have six million
subscribers I don't deserve six million
subscribers not yet like my stuff isn't
good enough yet I'm not good enough yet
our process isn't good enough yet the
research isn't good enough yet editing
is a good enough yet it's not good
enough yet like you guys don't watch
every single video that I make on the
channel and then instantly share it with
your friends every meeting we make
doesn't go viral because it's not good
enough some of them take off and blow up
when others don't I didn't provide
enough value to you guys you don't want
to share it and that's not on you it's
not like my audience sucks and you don't
share it I'm so good and they're not
sharing it it's on them it's on it's on
my audiences they're not sharing my
stuff or it's the YouTube algorithm that
stupid YouTube algorithm is destroying
me right as long as there's some other
reason then I'm not going to work harder
to get better so I don't deserve to have
six million subscribers I'm not down on
myself I deserve to have the 600 k I'm
happy with that I did a lot of work to
get here I'm not saying that I suck I
don't suck I'm good but I'm not six
million good I need to get there I want
to get better I'm hungry to get there I
want to add more value to you guys I
look up to other speakers who had tons
of success like Les Brown and Tony
Robbins and I want to learn from them to
make myself better and so you deserve to
be where you are if you produce good
stuff in this era it will take off it's
so easy to share there are no gig
keepers there are no limits anymore
there's nobody that you need to get in
touch with and that person is going to
make you a star you can make yourself a
star now problem is you're not good
enough yet and that's a hard killed at
all but if you do swallow it and you
accept it then it forces you to get
better and the good thing is you realize
that you have the tools to go out and
get better you can change the course of
your life because you don't rely on
gatekeepers or anybody else making you a
star you can make it happen for yourself
if you want to put in the work to get in
there there is nobody holding you back
from achieving success like yourself so
the question they today is I'm curious
what's the reason you're telling
yourself you're not more successful I'm
curious are you blaming somebody else or
have you blamed somebody or something
else in the past I'm curious leave it
down the comments below will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout at that Tommy Gonzales comi thank
you so much i picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and i hope
you're enjoying the reason thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and i'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot I believe nations thank
you so much for watching if you want to
learn more about this subject get a
little bit deeper on it I'm going to
share it's an extra bonus clips that I
hope you'll enjoy I don't understand the
industry I don't understand I don't
understand where music is headed I don't
really understand technology I just know
that when you walk into a club and you
see a band that blows you away you are
going to follow that band you're going
to either buy their CD or you're going
to find them online are you going to see
them the next time they come to play you
don't have to stand in line at the song
contest on TV to become a popular
musician you know product placement and
labels and anr people and all at
[ __ ] it doesn't matter I swear to
god it doesn't matter and if
you back that up with the idea that just
playing those great songs in your great
live band is enough reward for you can
you're set but you've got to be badass
you just have to be really good it's the
other things that make up for your
musical inability you know I mean as a
drummer I never felt like I'm going to
be on the cover of modern journal
magazine because I'm the best drummer in
the world I just do that if you put me
on stage without PA or floor monitors in
a small club that I would beat the [ __ ]
out of my drums so much that people go
god damn did you see that drummer whoa
[Music]